hey guys I'm Dan I'm Jeff and this is
game sport news but before we get
started we just want to apologize for a
something we got wrong yesterday we said
that she could get torchlight in
torchlight 2 for free when in actual
fact you have to actually own it before
you can get it for free from good-old
you can get a drm-free coffee if you
already own it on Steam but you can't
actually just get it for free sorry
sorry
first up in sad news for Dragon Age fans
Michael Laidlaw creative director of the
series has announced his left Bioware
Laidlaw made the announcement on Twitter
that after 14 years he will be leaving
the studio Laidlaw has worked on pretty
much every big Bioware franchise
including Jade Empire Mass Effect and
Dragon Age as recently as June he had
spoken about something happening with
Dragon Age but it seems whatever that is
he won't be a part of it in the
statement Laidlaw says that he has every
confidence that the world we've created
together is in good hands and that he'll
spend the near future reconnecting with
all the amazing games and worlds that my
peers have created if he's ready to move
on I mean we see that happen all the
time with games industry veterans which
he very much is and that's great for him
I am slightly concerned for the Dragon
Age series just because I love all the
Dragon games that have come out so far
even Inquisition I was a really big fan
of so for him to depart it's giving me
Casey Hudson vibes yeah who of course
was you know it completely imperative in
the creation of the original Mass Effect
trilogy and then left and then Andromeda
happened but I would hope that bio is
kind of learned it's lesson and there's
still a lot of great people on that team
edie boon creative director at nether
realm the guys who make Mortal Kombat
and the injustice games has spoken about
the DC fighting game maybe making its
way to the Nintendo switch speaking to
games but at the Brazil game show Byrne
theorized it would be possible to get
injustice to running on switch oh there
would be some shortcomings saying I
think at the end of the day you can make
almost any game there are inevitable
compromises but you know you can make
some version of injustice on the Atari
2600 it's not gonna be great but I bet
you can make something if they were to
develop a title for Nintendo's hybrid
console it seems like some outsourcing
might be in order when asked about his
interest in exploring switch games Byrne
responded it is a pretty different
hardware architecture it's not like you
can go from a PlayStation 4 to a switch
really easily so I think we would need
to set up something in terms of an
external team fella this year Boone held
a Twitter poll asking which platform
fans would like to see injustice on
switch or Vita with the switch winning
out it seems the idea of a bunch of
players getting together with their
systems to duke it out in an injustice
tournament is something the dev is
interested in we'll be sure to keep you
updated if we hear anything more on this
one finally games one has the chance to
sit down with xbox boss Phil Spencer
and talk about everything from his
destiny power level to cross play
between Xbox and Playstation
Spencer logged 700 hours in bungees
original space loot game but so far has
only reached power level 237 in destiny
2 the fact that he's not high enough to
raid yet apparently keeps him awake at
night for me it's more of the crushing
loneliness of my existence when asked
about the Xbox one expensive maintain
that the new console like the Xbox elite
controller isn't for everyone he expects
the Xbox one asked to be the big market
seller with the enthusiasts demographic
being the ones to pick up the new
hardware one thing Spencer wanted to set
straight was the idea that gamers aren't
taking advantage of the Xbox one
backwards compatibility program when
asked about a report Ars Technica
published in June that stated only one
and a half percent of the more than one
point six five billion minutes spent on
Xbox one by a sample of almost a million
users who spent playing backwards
compatible games
Spencer responded a lot of the data is
their party data so I can't really tell
you how many people are playing a
certain game it's not my game I think
the best signal we had so far is when
black ops 2 landed and that month it hit
MPD's top ten that month for game sales
an Xbox 360 game that's years old that
shows that people care
Microsoft is still on track to add
original Xbox games to the program this
year with Spencer saying they're really
close and that there's still some
specifics about how the compatibility
will work that quote people will find
pretty interesting
finally when asked about where cross
play currently stands between Microsoft
and Sony Spencer said we talked to Sony
all the time with Minecraft on
PlayStation we have to be one of the
biggest games on their platform in terms
of sales and gameplay same with Nintendo
they've been great supporters and we
continue to collaborate with them but I
think Sony's view is different you
should talk about what their view is oh
[ __ ] hang on I got the perfect app for
this I've got the perfect app oh god
yeah that's not gonna turn around
is that what all the millenials done
there's a nice really long delay I'm
young I'm beyond lucky wall cross-play
isn't a technical issue as for tonight
accidentally and able to feature
recently hopefully a middle ground can
be found between the heavy hitters so we
can all play video games together that's
sweet
there's heaps more than that Phil
Spencer interview that you can check out
over on GameSpot and we'll be back
tomorrow with the top 5 stories of the
entire work we hope to see you then he
expects Xbox one asked to be the big
market seller with the enthusiastic
demographic resist
[Laughter]